we have the Steve Balance Centers
Wilfred you know he's been in court
today he was convicted of two counts uh
two crimes of not appearing uh before a
congressional committee that wanted to
hear from him with regard to the January
the sixth Insurrection sentence has now
been handed down he's been sentenced to
four months in prison and fined six and
a half thousand dollars but that has
been stayed pending appeal which he
intends to proceed with no that could
take anything up to and Beyond a year so
he walks from court but he has been
convicted we knew that already today he
has been sentenced four months and six
and a half thousand dollars far short of
what the prosecution was after they
wanted a maximum jail term of two years
and a maximum fine of 200 000 so
something short of what they were after
balance defense lawyers they had wanted
probation they argued that that that he
was protected by executive privilege
that was knocked out by the judge who
disagreed and following conviction he's
now handed down that sentence we await
to hear whether or not uh Bannon will
have words for us after his appearance
he did have something to say on his way
inside the federal court let's have a
listen
remember
this illegitimate regime their their
judgment day is on 8th November when the
bite Administration ends I want to thank
you all for coming thanks
but I'm talking about the 8th of
November that of course the U.S midterm
elections the question is of course with
regard to this January the sixth
committee and subpoenas in general is
the other individual who for whom a
subpoena is in the post Donald Trump
himself we expect more uh word on that
and when it will actually be sent to him
later today but this January the sixth
committee it wants to hear from the
former president bannon's appearance and
his sentence today will no doubt
concentrate the mind of Donald Trump but
uh you know there are issues around
dragging Donald Trump before the
committee that there were not perhaps
with Steve Bannon all sorts of legal
obstacles with regard to a former
president issues of timing as well
because of the midterms depending on how
they go then the this committee could be
wrapped up and with it the subpoena
itself so Donald Trump we are wait to
hear how he will respond to this
particular subpoena but he is a man
facing legal troubles on a number of
fronts and frankly I think the business
of this committee and The subpoena that
it will send to him probably today
uh it uh is probably the least of his
worries I understand we've heard from
Steve Bannon on his exit from Court
let's have a listen to what he had to
say
can't we all just get along that's not
my line
um anyway uh
so as you know Mr Bannon was sentenced
today
as usual we love that vote as usual uh
the judge listened carefully and uh
entered a decision that he thought was
appropriate we certainly fully respect
the judge's decision but uh we will be
filing a notice of appeal as the judge
indicated
um very grateful to the judge for
thinking through the issues uh candidly
and uh it's an extraordinary move to
permit a stay pending appeal that was
the appropriate move there are the
standard is whether the case raises
substantial issues that reasonable
jurists could differ over meaning is
there a solid chance for an appeal uh to
be successful and there certainly is
more than that in that in this case I've
said before and I would uh confirm it I
believe that the appeal in this case is
Bulletproof the issue is the
Constitutional issues involved in this
case are very important but Mr Bannon
never got to tell uh the reasons for his
actions with respect to the subpoena
never got to tell this story because
because the government insists the
government assisted from day one on
prohibiting any mention any evidence or
any discussion to go before the jury as
to why Mr Bannon reacted as he did to
the subpoena on the advice of council
thank you very much look forward to
adjudicating your silence
his sons was in my direction
by the way I want to say one thing I
respect uh the judge the sentence he
came down with today is his decision I
fully respect I've been totally
respectful of this entire process on the
legal side
I also want to make one other statement
before I talk about a broader topic
more than any person in the Trump
Administration
I testify before the Mueller commission
for more hours I testified in front of
uh shift and the house intelligence
committee more than any other person in
the Trump Administration I attest I
testified in front of the Senate
intelligence I think more than all about
the issues related uh to uh to Russia
gate to all of that okay the same
process every time I had lawyers that
were engaged they worked through the
issues of privilege and at that time I
went and testified and and this thing
about uh I'm above the law is an
absolute and total lie now more
importantly
more importantly
the judge today was my Judgment Day by
the judge and he stated and for the
appeal and we'll have a very vigorous
appeals process I've got a great legal
team and there'll be multiple areas of
appeal
but as that sign says right there can we
have the vote sign
on November 8th on November 8th on
November 8th there's going to have
judgment on the illegitimate Biden
regime and quite frankly and quite
frankly Nancy Pelosi and the entire
committee and we know which way that's
going
either they've already been turfed out
like Liz Cheney right or I've quit like
kinzinger and other the Democrats
or they're about to be beaten like luria
and others
or they will lose their power and become
a minority and Nancy Pelosi and and
Tom's chairman Champs is all of it
this is a this is a this is democracy
this is democracy the American people
are way in measuring what went on with
the justice department and how they
comported themselves they're weighing
and measuring that right now and they
will vote on November 8th they will hang
on they will vote they will they will
notice your silence they will know
anything you want to say to them can I
go ahead and finish can I thanks
on November 8th on November 8th the
American people will raise judgment and
we will groom the Biden Administration
ends on the eighth evening of the 8th of
November and let me be let me some other
thing is that the Department of Justice
Merrick Garland will end up being the
first attorney general that's brought up
on charges impeachment and heebly will
removed from office thank you very much
there you go Steve Bonnet outside that
federal court building a party political
broadcast on behalf of Steve Bannon
rather there he had much to say outside
Court he had nothing to say in terms of
giving evidence on his own behalf inside
Court his lawyer today at sentencing
described the January the sixth
committee as a partisan political body
with no interest in investigation All
Eyes now turn to Donald Trump with
regard to the January 6 committee and
its subpoena for Donald Trump but
likewise he has dismissed its work as a
high-level political Witch Hunt whether
or not we see the former president
before his January the sixth inquisitors
on that committee is very much an open
question
peace thanks so much